أصبحت الطرق في إدلب مرة أخرى مزدحمة
بسبب حركة الأرواح اليائسة التي
انضموا إلى مئات الآلاف
المحشورين بالفعل على الحدود التركية كما لو
أن هذا القرب يمكن أن يوفر بطريقة ما
الخلاص ، فإن المخيمات المؤقتة عبارة عن
حفر طينية أو مياه الصرف الصحي ممزوجة بمياه الأمطار التي
تتجه نحو الأعلى.
فر محمد البالغ من العمر 11 عامًا من الخيام بعد أن
استولى برميل متفجر على نصف منزله
، حيث تم تغطية
الغبار الأبيض بإخوته وأشقاؤه بأعجوبة حيث لم يصب
الانفجار الغرفة التي كانوا
يختبئون بها ،
إلا أن مفهومًا نسبيًا هو
الراحة التي توفرها أربعة جدران  النظافة ،
يبدو الأمر وكأنه حلم بعيد المنال ،
لا تستطيع جدّة محمد ، حديشة ، بالكاد أن تجد
ما يكفي من الماء النظيف لتغتسل ، لم تستحم
منذ أكثر من شهر ،
الأطفال يمرضون جميعًا ، وهي ليست
متأكدة تمامًا من أنهم سيكونون بأمان هنا
، حيث تأخذ قوات النظام المدعومة من الروس
على المزيد من الأراضي التي يسيطر عليها المتمردون ، الخوف من
أن الرعب ليس جزءًا جديدًا من
حلقة أصبحت الآن حقيقة خطيرة حيث
لا يعرف الآباء  كيفية حماية
أطفالهم وحياتهم ليست أكثر من مجرد
قضاء ساعات في فترة 10 أيام
هذا الشهر قتل حوالي مائة
مدني ثلثهم من
الأطفال في هذا الفيديو الذي
صورته الخوذات البيضاء في ريف حلب وهي
أم قاتمة.  تلتقط
الأوساخ جثة ابنها محمد شيخ رئيسة البالغ من العمر 14 عامًا ،
فلا يوجد عزاء لهذا النوع من
الألم ، والألم الذي يشعر به الكثير من المقتطفات التي تم
طمسها معًا وعدد لا يحصى من مقاطع الفيديو
التي ظهرت على مدار السنوات التسع
الماضية ،
لا يرحم الله  سامحكم بالرصاص ، هذه
المرأة تصرخ ، عامل الإنقاذ يجري
أمامها صارخًا أين هم
يخرجون بسرعة ، يصرخ في
الأطفال الذين يبحثون عن الجرحى.
على
الأطفال العميقين ولكن الذين لم يعالجوا أولئك
الذين يعيشون في هذه القذارة محظوظين
بالمقارنة حتى بدون أحذية أو مأوى مناسب ،
فإنهم على الأقل أربعة على قيد الحياة الآن على
الرغم من دكلا  حصص وقف إطلاق النار
والاسم فقط والاستنكار يستمر
مثل فيلم مروّع عن تكرار سرقة
الطفولة قبل أن يتمكنوا حتى من
بدء ويل شيطاننا الذي يتعثر